the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight spoiler filled video today I have
some major news thanks to another
youtuber who goes by the name of freaky
doctor now for those of you who aren't
familiar what the youtuber you should
know that this isn't the first time he
has had some major spoilers last season
I watched a few of his videos about the
season 7 plot leaked and they were the
most accurate leaks I have ever seen
he somehow knew way more than just the
main plot points he actually knew most
of the dialogue that was going to be
said and at least some of the episodes
when I heard he posted a video about the
season 8 spoilers I Olbia silly got very
excited because I know how accurate he
was last season if you would like to
watch his full video I will put the
links down below in the description that
way you can go and see for yourself what
I am about to tell you today is pretty
damn crazy if it's true also please do
me a favor try not to leave these
spoilers and other youtubers comment
sections there are some other Game of
Thrones youtubers that do not want to
know any of the spoilers so please do
not go and tell them unless they talk
about them on their own I only want to
show these things to people that want to
know I would appreciate it if you could
do the same thank you very much now
let's get into it
according to freaky doctor there will be
a major scene in the dragon pit during
the finale of season 8 we already know
the cast was filming in this area based
on previous reports and photos that have
come out but I would never have guessed
this is what they were filming in that
dragon pit apparently there will be a
trial held at the dragon pit where
Tyrion Lannister will face charges of
being a traitor that's right ladies and
gentlemen if this is correct
Tyrion Lannister will betray Jon and
Daenerys next season not only that but
he will be sentenced to death and that
sentence will be carried out Tyrion
Lannister will die in the finale
is that they have film at trial yes a
trial and you may wonder and who is
going to be judged in that trial well
Tyrion Lannister is being yet in that
trial in the dragon pit and what will be
the most shocking moment of course
Tyrians
death this is an absolute bombshell I
know most of us have suspected Tyrion
could be up to something sketchy
we all remember he went and visited his
sister after their first meeting of the
dragon pit and we never got to see how
that conversation ended then we all saw
the look on Tyrians face when John went
into Danny's cabin to have sex
deep down I'm really hoping this is not
true I do not want to see Tyrion die as
a traitor but I know freaky doctor has
been correct so many times before
I'm afraid he's probably right again the
dragon pit scenes are filmed in Spain
and if I'm not mistaken Fricke doctorís
from spain as well so perhaps he had
some inside connections during the
filming of the scenes I do not know but
I got to be honest with you I was blown
away by the revelation I have always
said I am expecting some of the
characters that I love to die but I
always thought Tyrion would survive
everything then again some of us have
been assuming someone in Danny's camp
was feeding Cersei information and
regardless of how the Lannisters may
have treated each other over the years
we've always known Tyrion loves his
family but now that Jaime has left
Cersei I thought this would be even more
incentive for Tyrion to help take her
down because he loves Jaime more than he
does Cersei so could this be the big
twist in the end Jaime ends up as an
alliance with the Starks in Tyrion
betrays them Tyrion was making me
suspicious but I did not expect it to go
so far that it would lead to his death I
know this is not confirmed information
but I am shocked by this spoiler I don't
even know to say I suppose if this is
true this would make the third time
Tyrion has stood on trial and faced
charges you know what they always say
the third time is the charm
do you believe Tyrion will betray Jon
and Daenerys and do you think it will
lead to his death
leave me your thoughts on this because I
really want to hear what other people
have to say about this spoiler let's
talk about it in the comment section I
just wanted to make a quick video about
it because I was completely stunned and
I just need to talk to someone about
this so I will see you down below also
don't forget about the giveaway that
link is down below too I'm giving away a
copy of the road of Ice and Fire book if
you would like to enter for a chance to
win just click on that link and follow
the easy instructions good luck everyone
and thank you very much for stopping by
and watching the video have a great day
I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]